usan una firma que cambió la historia el
4 de abril de 1949 nació el organización
para el tratado del atlántico norte es
conocida como otan fue una alianza de
defensa colectiva y en su nacimiento
estuvo formada por doce países que
coincidían en ver a la unión soviética
como una amenaza después paulatinamente
entraron grecia turquía alemania y
españa- y en 1999 llegarían los primeros
satélites de la ya extinta unión
soviética hungría polonia y república
checa en 2004 accedieron siete países
donde destacaban aliados soviéticos del
pacto de varsovia y las ex repúblicas
soviéticas bálticas como letonia
lituania y estonia
la ampliación terminó con las anexiones
de croacia y albania en 2009 la de
montenegro en 2017 y la definitiva la de
macedonia del norte en 2020 30 países en
total vladimir putin ha acusado a la
otan de violar su supuesta promesa de no
expandirse más allá de sus fronteras de
1990 mientras el conflicto escaló en
2008 con una declaración de la otan en
la cumbre de bucarest los aliados de la
otan dieron la bienvenida las
aspiraciones euroatlánticas de ucrania y
georgia para ser miembros recordaron que
estos países se convertirán en miembros
de la otan fue justo en 2008 cuando
estalló la guerra de georgia el país del
cáucaso intentó recuperar la región
controlada por rusia de osetia del sur
pero terminó también perdiendo abjasia
otra región separatista rusa en
territorio georgiano y en 2014 rusia
anexo la península de crimea en ucrania
que es también su salida al mar negro es
por eso que ahora rusia exige que el
bloque occidental adquiera compromisos
en materia de seguridad rechazando una
eventual integración de ucrania la
alianza militar y el retiro de la
infraestructura castrense instalada en
europa el este después de 1997 la otan
asegura que cada país es libre de elegir
sus alianzas y dice que no cerrará su
política de puertas abiertas